foreign
[Music]
news about Deadpool 3 never ceases not
only have more characters been confirmed
to return in the sequel once again but
the start of filming is also ill-fated
due to the writer strike in the United
States but let's start with the good
news Brianna Hildebrand is now back for
the third time as the mutant negasonic
teenage Warhead her superpower causing
nuclear explosions at her side as in
Deadpool 2 is shioli kutsuna who will
again play her friend Yukio the
contrasting pair of a badass fighter and
her rather sweet companion already made
for some laughs in the last film we
certainly look forward to Wade Wilson's
Splendid crushes on Yukio and negasonic
teenage Warheads annoyed eye rolling
Deadpool fans can rest easy that the
third film won't do it all over in the
MCU at Disney either at least as far as
the cast is concerned in addition to
newcomer Hugh Jackman as Wolverine Ryan
Reynolds has meanwhile gathered numerous
characters from the predecessors around
him from cab driver to Pinder to
roommate blind Al to Wade's fiancee
Vanessa the metal giant Colossus and
perhaps the most powerful superhero of
all time X-Force member Peter as
collider reports filming for Deadpool 3
has since begun this is in fact a reason
to Rejoice but there is a catch since
the writer strike is still going on
those responsible are obliged to stick
word for word to what is written in the
script so far any deviation is
prohibited as is a well-known fact
however the Deadpool films thrive on the
fact that a lot of improvisation takes
place on set and the creators later have
a wide selection of gags from which to
choose the best what this means for the
final result is written in the stars but
it leaves us with a queasy feeling we
hope that the strike will end soon and
give Reynolds and the team plenty of
opportunity to incorporate the typical
Deadpool magic into the movie The
theatrical release of Deadpool 3 is
scheduled for November 8 2024.
foreign
[Music]